[Music]
hi i'm carl tuckerson and welcome back
to white privilege tonight with
thanksgiving upon us and our american
values in jeopardy we're going to hear
from our national crt correspondent
becky sue
some of you may recognize her from your
facebook eyebrow acting group becky sue
welcome to the show hey carl where are
you calling us from well i'm hiding in
my bathroom why are you whispering
because my boyfriend's parents are here
and they're the worst they're worse than
the worst they're libs they've been
going on and on about joe biden and
equality blah blah it's like freaking
wokes giving around here oh my god i can
only imagine oh it's bad it's real bad
first they were going on knowing about
january 6th being a bad thing which is
crazy and they were talking about that
cutie pie kyle ridden house
and they hate him of course so i brought
up crt
seeing that's how it's ruining my future
step foster kids uh chrysler and dodge
crt is truly ruining our children them
kids is here but their daddy ain't he's
my boyfriend bobby he's down at the
police station fulfilling his community
service obligation
i mean
doing his very important patriot work
washing the police cars so anyways i
said his parents that the libs are
poisoning kids with crt
and it ain't right i'm pretty much an
expert on the subject i did a bunch of
research one day uh last week on
facebook and uh that shonies has real
good weekly so i pretty much got the
best info out there too what did they
say well first they said that i didn't
know what i was talking about and they
try to trip me up ask me what crt stood
for like i didn't even know of course
you know what it stands for
well duh
it's critical rice
training because they're training our
kids to hate their race they're training
them to hate racism if it's not even
their birthright and stuff it's just sad
and then i said the patriot pilgrims
didn't act all embarrassed of their
whiteness when the native americans came
into their town looking for free corn
and stuff the pilgrims gave them lots of
food they gave them like fish
and
donuts
and spaghetti and the native americans
were grateful they didn't go make their
little kids learn cpr i mean crt in
school so
bobby's parents got all quiet and their
jaws were like on the floor and they
didn't know what to say
so i won that fight
had a girl becky sue well i gotta go see
if bobby's back from doing his uh very
important police work and grab myself
another hard lemonade becky sue thanks
for coming on the show well thanks for
having me carl i'm such a big fan of
yours i love your bow tie
anyways happy thanksgiving
next up we find out which flavor of mayo
is best to put on your thanksgiving
turkey
[Music]